joining me here right now is Jamal Adams
how are you Jamal how you doing you tell
me Jamal how should I be doing you woke
up this morning my hat slightly good I
like it now Jamal very rarely do I start
an interview this way but things have
been so crazy with the Jets which you
know I grew up loving the Jets right you
know I'm from New York City from Staten
Island New York the je T us is a team
that I have been living and dying with
for quite some time so I asked this
question with I asked this question with
no hint of irony sarcasm but genuine
genuine ask how was your spleen today
everything okay all right your spleen is
good all the internal organs were good
coming off the bye week fine so what
you're saying no doubt okay 98.6 is your
temperature we're good yeah everything's
good okay can you tell me who your
starting quarterback is gonna be this
week Jamal Adams who's starting this
week what do you think no I have no I
have no idea man I have no idea
whoever it is is definitely gonna be
ready we just we just got to give we got
to get back healthy obviously man that's
that's the main thing well in terms of
that I want to get to the defense in a
second when was the last time you saw
Sam Donald my personally I bought him
one time saw him in there today
he was actually in there okay in the
training room he had a nice little sweat
going okay but other than that that was
the last time I seen him man does he
look like he lost weight too you know he
looks like he looks like Sam I haven't
really idolized like looked him up you
know sometimes you haven't seen somebody
in like a week or two like you know hey
it looks like you lost somebody but good
man okay
I'll talk to him I've talked to him he's
in good spirits he you know he's just
eager to get back out there
I bet this has got to just drive him
crazy it's gotta be drunk yeah
yeah I mean who would've thought you
know what I mean who know what no one
would have seen this coming a lot of
adversity for us you know obviously but
you know tough times don't last
so how are you handling it how are you
handling the only three start so far
yeah it's tough man I'm not gonna lie to
you you know I'm just trying to stay as
positive as possible this could continue
to you know work hard continue to better
myself with it for the team and continue
to keep the team together you know that
that that's really my main focus man
okay well I'm gonna say this Jamal Adams
because you know you were on my show
before your draft and I told you I told
you I wanted the Jets to get you I told
you that and now I remember I did this
okay and you know I'm I am a
professional but I do on this show
certainly share you know my hopes and
beliefs and that's why I'm I should my
name's on the show that's my setup to
saying this here am i and my years of
being a New York sports fan when I have
had the opportunity to tell somebody who
I believe is so vitally important to the
team's victory as well as locker-room
presence and culture change I want to
make sure everything's fine are you and
the Jets okay with each other right now
Jamal Adams yeah yeah
you know obviously I see a lot of people
you know and I hear about people you
know saying that you know people the
Jets are you know they should trade me
and all this man I'm not I'm not focused
on that man I'm in New York jet you know
I'm excited to be here I'm focused on
the team right now I'm focused on you
know trying to you know better myself
for the team like I said and you know
keep to keep the guys together you know
anytime I step on the field I'm going to
give them all and you know as long as I
can do that that's that's just how I
bring what I bring to the game you know
what I mean and what I what I can do to
you know keep the energy out up there on
the field like I said we just got to get
healthy and continue to bring the energy
like we're always doing and you know
stick together as a group and we'll be
fine well again I don't I'm not asking
this based on my concern or I don't
think I think I speak for all judgments
when I say it's not Jamal Adams can
learn about your level of play or what
percentage you bring to the to the table
when you suit up and play I mean that
there's no doubt it's the proverbial
110% it's it's it's them kind of
understanding you did you get benched at
the end of that game against the bronze
did that actually happen um
I mean to me that that was a you know I
got benched but you know you know we we
sat down and we talked about it they
didn't really see it as you know
benching me they just wanted it to you
know show a way of calming me down they
thought I was a little bit out of
control they didn't want to get me
kicked out for the next game but I
definitely would never do that to hurt
the team but you know it was it was
definitely it was hard to you know be
taken out obviously
that's never happened to me since I've
been playing ball but you know we've
moved on it there's there's no love lost
you know with the coaching staff and I
mean we're on the same page and we're
excited to get back out there
jamal adams jet safety here on the Rich
Eisen show are you aware that that Jets
fans do place this level of hoping you
and your and your abilities are you
aware of the amount of hope that Jets
fans place in you Jamal Adams and how
much they are looking at you and already
see what your talent level is and what
you bring to the table are you aware of
how many people are on their hands and
knees for you yeah I want to do
everything in my power to change this
organization and get it to where people
you know want to see men especially jet
fans and like I said everybody has that
mindset in the locker room everybody you
know once wants to get it changed and
obviously it didn't start off the way we
wanted it and obviously you know a lot
of a lot of injuries occurred a lot of
you know adversity hit hit home for us
early on and hopefully we can get over
I strongly believe we can and I strongly
believe the locker room is is is really
strong and you know the coaching staff
is is on the same page we're all on the
same page and we just got to keep our
head down and keep working and move
forward now few more minutes left with
Jamal Adams before we get to loonatics I
want to ask you about LSU and where they
are right now with Joe burrow and this
program so many people have a lot of
hopes and and desires about that program
right now the offense that you're seeing
out there coach openness offense out
there with Joe burrow saying how this is
as different as anybody seen at LSU what
do you think yeah it's really different
man I tweeted out something not long ago
man if we had this office when I was in
school I would add two or three you ask
me they're very very diverse on the
opposite side they're very creative
and they do they do things that keep
businesses on their toes and when you
can do that and you know you have
playmakers on the offensive side you
have playmakers I'm really all around on
the team it's a special group it's a
special thing you can do and you know
I'm excited for those guys those guys
are definitely rolling we got some big
test coming up and it's really going to
speak for how we are as a team and you
know we haven't really hit adversity
early on so you know it's going to come
and you know hopefully when it does come
we beat it and I believe in those guys I
believe in that desk staff over there
they're well coached and they're gonna
definitely be well prepared and you know
I'm always pulling for that for the
purple and gold you know and I always
say man I miss I miss you too each and
every day it's a special place well I'm
wondering I don't know how much you're
aware of it going about your business of
being a professional football player of
a high caliber but the state of
California is just signed a bill the
governor just signed a bill into law
allowing eventually student athletes at
universities in California to make money
off their image likeness as well as
their name
I'm wondering what more I think about
this development Jamal Adams well you
know I'm not gonna get too far into it I
definitely agree I think you know it's a
great plan and you know I'm excited to
those for the for the future you know I
mean as far as in college sports and
those guys getting taken care of and I'm
all for it because it is it is sometimes
that you go through as a college student
that people don't really understand and
you know when when you don't have that
that certain meal or you don't have you
know clothes or whatever whatever it is
you know extra extra
you know tokens in in your pocket is
definitely helpful but those guys you
know they should be paid you know for
not only you know things off the field
but you know their brand their their
likeness you know they should be paid
off for those things so I'm definitely
pulling forward and I definitely support
them well and in terms of that I mean
you're a representative right now of
lunatics which is a ticket site that
lets fans reserve playoff tickets for
any team in any game all year long
and when their team makes the game they
just get the tickets we could talk about
that a little bit here and to me I mean
why not let somebody like you do it when
you're LSU as opposed to Jets right yeah
like you said you know lunatics is is is
giving fans the greatest sports year of
their life by giving away golden tickets
you know across the country and you know
like you said whoever gets the ticket
will receive two tickets to you know
every home playoff game in their city
including the Super Bowl and you know
you know it lasts through the end of
next year so all you have to do is just
go to you know go to lunatics calm it's
very simple the the registration is free
and you know if you hopefully hopefully
you get the golden ticket man I think
it's awesome do ya lunatics with an X
LUN a TI XCOM and you're given in one
way on your Twitter account at the Adams
era which I follow
that president mal on on Instagram as
well before I let you go Jamal
did you ask O'Dell word where did that
watch deal come from how come you can't
isn't it an LSU thing or just motel
thing when you saw him yeah his fame and
exposure there's a little bit bigger
than mine man not know so you know
Richard Richard definitely gave him some
love and you know I'm with it what a
couple watches man so that's that's a
huge honor man so um you know I'll just
I'll support him from afar man I wish I
could have them little deal yeah I know
and also by the way with with that also
comes with you being told to get off the
field because of your visor I'm a third
and goal that comes to write with Odell
hey man I think he has enough funds to
take care of those fine a Jamal let's
chat more often than when we do I really
love the way you play the game really
really do Jamal and I look forward to
seeing you out there the rest of the
year maybe I can get that golden ticket
for the AFC Championship game at MetLife
what do you think man I won't put any
pressure on anybody or say anything man
we just got to tell you one game at a
time you got to take care of yourself
Jamal we'll see out there on something
Thank You Man you got that Jamal Adams
Jets safety for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app